and here is chris [ __ ]
boom it's 6-3 220. he's well built got a
good starting pitchers build if he can
go five would be great
six will be fine and bubitch
first pitch is hit to center field
witt's first move was back
and now he adjusts so a good start for
bubic one pitch
and one away anthony rizzo is two for
eight with a couple of singles
in the series oh there's the changeup
and and they're two down in the first
inning so two out to nobody on the
battery is javier baez
one ball two strikes he deals
and it's in there strike three called at
97 miles an hour
starting pitcher for the cubs two starts
one up one down 2.70 era
continuing the work he did second half
of 2019.
with maryfield leader in consecutive
games play
260th straight game
swing and a miss he got him two gone no
score bottom of the first
and the batter is ryan o'hearn now the
one two from the cub right hand are you
darvish
swinging a fly ball well hit center
field but very playable for horner
he loves it and it's a one two three
first inning
now wilson contreras now the wine in one
two pitch swung on and missed he struck
him out
that's three straight strikeouts for
chris bovich david bodie is the batter
two and two down he goes that is
six up and six down with four strikeouts
for chris
two on with one out double plays in
order but
we got one of the speedier guys in the
league coming up to hit
ground ball they get one they get two
against a speedy batter runner mondassy
and darvish is pumped up
michael franco bats eighth tonight
lined to left field schwarber is back
and that's going to sail over his head
and michael franco has another extra
base hit
he has 12 hits as a royal seven have
been for extra bases
batter for the royals would be lopez
nicki the number nine hit her up for the
first time
from the high set checks the runner at
second payoff pitch
and he'll line it into right field
hayward plays it on a bounce
franco holds it third so nikki lopez
does better than a bunt
and puts runners at first and third and
nobody out brings up with mere fields
first and third for the royals nobody
down two and one on with the pitch
and whit will bounce it off the
pitcher's glove second baseman has it
he'll fire her first for the out if the
score comes
franco as bodhi throws out wit and
actually they get
lopez as well so they get the double
play the royals do score a run
let's have two men on a single and a
walk the table is set for javier bayer
[Music]
and bias in the air right field
and it is fair bryant's gonna score
and baez i don't know if he waited out
of the box
but he knocks in bryant and it's one to
one that's a mistake
so he gets an rbi as he knocks in bryant
and here is wilson contreras and the one
two from booby
cone first bounces one of the shortstop
a run will score that brought a second
for one over to first a double play
no rbi but rizzo does come in the score
and the cubs lead
two to one now it's owen two you've got
mary field at third ryan o'hearn
at the plate one away the stretch the
lead at third by
merryfield in the pit a fastball strike
three call
got him on the inside corner you're not
out of the woods yet
because the cleanup batter salvador
perez is coming up
from the stretch garbage fire perez hits
a tapper slowly
short stop sign bias has it flips to
first gets it
excellent job by garbage here's chris
bryant two down nobody on
ian kennedy ready for the old wand
o'brien
he bounces to franco backhands and
slings slow throw
and o'hare couldn't dig it out the
inning will continue
on a throwing error marissa with the
plate cubs lead 2-1 8th inning let's see
if he can put it in play somewhere
he does hit a sharp ground ball in the
right center field a base hit
bryant's gonna go to third the throw
goes to second bryant stops at third
rizzo again with that short stroke with
two strikes
wraps out a base hit right-hander to
right-hander
kennedy's pitch bias it's a line drive
that's going to be a base hit to right
an insurance run is in bryant crosses
the plate
opposite field one scoring single javier
baez rizzo stops at second
cubs lead three to one here is contreras
and a line shot base hit to right
coming around third and scoring is rizzo
it's four to one nice salvage by
contreras
ninth inning here in kansas city cubs
lead four to one
and ian hat batting a swing and a smash
that's going to be a fair ball into the
left field corner
down the line bouncing off the wall
chasing it down as gordon getting it
back in
lead off double in half
chris bryant out into left center this
ball is going to be cut off by
merrifield he bobbles it carratini
racing around third he's gonna try to
score the relay to the plate caratini
head first slide save
at the plate and the cubs now lead six
to one
cubs are one out away from improving
their record to
ten and two this will be their sixth
consecutive win
a ball and two strikes on gordon boils
down to their last strike
ray delivers swinging a missed strike
three and the cubs have won
six in a row cubs wins six to one
they're ten
and two to start the season